la ciudadanía tiene que hacer un
esfuerzo económico proporcional al
esfuerzo que hacen nuestros militares
así justificó el presidente Manuel
macron el aumento en el presupuesto de
las fuerzas armadas y la inteligencia ha
anunciado hoy desde montemarzán en esta
ciudad del sudeste francés macron
entregó el saludo de año nuevo a las
fuerzas armadas el presidente dijo que
el presupuesto para las fuerzas armadas
del 2024 del 2030 pasará a 400 mil
millones de euros eso es un tercio más
que en el período anterior cuando se
cambió una tendencia que era a disminuir
los gastos en defensa también anunció el
mandatario el aumento de un 60% del
gasto en inteligencia para tener una
guerra de avance una guerra de ventaja
dijo macron efectivamente la guerra en
Ucrania ha mostrado los puntos débiles
que tenía la estrategia de defensa
francesa su ejército y sus servicios de
inteligencia después de reparar a
nuestros militares a nuestros ejércitos
queremos transformarlos dijo el
presidente y dijo que esta inversión
servirá para mejorar nuestra herramienta
militar que permite salvaguardar nuestra
seguridad nuestra libertad nuestra
prosperidad y nuestro lugar en el mundo
en todo caso este nuevo presupuesto
tiene que ser aprobado por el parlamento
el debate será en el próximo verano